I was just thinking about South Park
again and one of the things we did that
maybe was inadvisable I watched South
Park with my sons particularly probably
from about sixth grade on and I I always
felt okay about it even though there was
some inappropriate stuff in there
because we discuss it all we talk
about is the I guess counter to that
that the Doom scrolling and the endless
amount information it's nice to have the
good information out there but that
thing also and the filters on pictures
and nobody thinks they look right and
all the rest of it screens are a problem
screens are no no doubt that screens are
part of of the distress that's going on
right now particularly for young people
so what do you do about that you know a
the cat is out of you to solve problem I
know the horse is out of the barn uh for
a lot of a lot of
generations and particularly sort of um
Millennial age they you're not going to
take them away from screens and gen Z
probably not either but you need to
there needs to be a consensus that of
limiting screen time for the younger
kids you've got to do it it's hard and
the only way it'll happen is if all
parents in every given Community do it
together because otherwise it'll be just
sharing screens during the day and stuff
right so yeah so okay so you have your
kids gota it's gonna be hard I've got
somebody for you they'll coach you up
yeah do you she's a psychologist that
just specializes in this area I can see
it now and everybody says oh well my
kids are never going to be the screens
and it's like yes you might want a nice
quiet dinner at a restaurant one night
and you hand them the iPad and then it's
5 years later and then they're just
whatever they do they're making cookies
on that thing I get it we we have
multiples when you're in survival mode
when you have multiples we absolutely
would have thrown thr our kids on screen
just to survive do you know about Miss
Rachel you know Miss Rachel Miss Rachel
is like this huge YouTuber and
supposedly she's like the one you know
she's an early
educator she's the one yeah but it's
like it's not flashy and it's not fast
and it's not destroy so she's the one so
basically the only thing I watch now is
Miss
Rachel but we don't even give even that
we try to limit it to just a few minutes
just before dinner so we can sit down
for a second but it's but I can see the
challenge and it's almost to me it
strikes me as just an unwinable there's
just no win because we all wish we were
better with these things even me a guy
that takes a month off in August and I
try not to tweet on weekends and all
that stuff nobody's perfect there's no
perfect parent we're screwed and your
kids will hate you for a little while
what you do you know how it goes but but
it's okay they'll be good they'll be
they'll be good um but uh yeah I was
just thinking about South Park again and
one of the things we did that maybe was
inadvisable I watched South Park with my
sons particularly probably from about
sixth grade on and I I always felt okay
about it even though there was some
inappropriate stuff in there because we
discussed it all we talk about and those
guys what is your take I i' I've been
dying
so what you're what you're referencing
for people that haven't seen is we've
put out a couple of these videos where
I'm watching South Park for the first
time which was it was my guy's idea so
the reason so you must have missed that
the reason that we did it the first time
was because I was a Simpsons guy so 1989
The Simpsons came out okay and I I Still
loveed The Cosby Show that was obviously
before Bill had well I guess he was
having his adventures but but there was
this big there was this big debate
because they were both on at the same
time which one was going to take over
and I loved Cosby and I loved the
Simpsons and then I went The Simpsons
route and then that was 89 and then
around 95 96 South Park came up but
Simpsons was you know Season s season 8
like Primo best years of The Simpsons
and I was just like I'm only going to
watch one cartoon that was my poliy and
then Family Guy came in around that and
then so yeah like later in the last 10
years I've watched some family guy that
but I just basically was just like no
I'm a Simpsons guy get and that's it
that's how I am with like Star Wars Lord
of the Rings I'm I like robots you know
the little Dwarfs with Harry for other
people this guy he loves you can do so
much so that's why so that's why never
watch it but but of course everyone's
always saying to me Dave you got did you
see this did you see so now we' started
watching them and I have to tell you
these people are ill
mentally they're ill but they have no no
it's so twisted and deep and dark weird
and insane and Brilliant they Crystal
brains they can see the future they it's
amazing they never they're always about
three years ahead of the game in in
Extreme Ways where you think oh my God
this over the I remember I did you see U
you're you're still ear well I'm all
over the place they just pick random one
so uh gentlemen get him the one where PC
principal is uh at the fraternity house
going down the hall with the yeah they
exact excited everybody is they like
brug use because when that happened I
thought Oh I thought oh my God you know
then I thought oh and now it happened
now it's actually happening now people
are doing that well even I did watch one
or they showed me one when they were
doing this member Berry thing that like
everything is just like a retread of
everything before and also sort of seems
I think sort of psychologically why
we're kind of screwed at the moment that
we can't as a society we don't create
anything new anymore we reboot Star Wars
we reskined you know a Marvel movie that
our dreams are now just becoming like
vestiges of an earlier more creative
time that's not healthy for a society
well but I I I don't I think it's a
combination of factors I mean I think
when things go negative there's a
natural Nostalgia why there would be
Nostalgia for the worst decade in
American history the 70s I cannot
imagine but there seems but be a little
80s come on 80s pretty 0s was lovely and
it was fun and that's that's the thing
that's missing now is fun right and the
80s were fun and so I'm seeing little
hints that maybe something like that is
is sort of emerging go ahead no well I
was just as you were saying that like it
seems to me also partly what's missing
is that we've so atomized sex now
because porn is now everywhere and it's
a private thing for people and it's like
we can joke about it but nobody talks
about it but like there's nothing sexy
anymore there's no there aren't sexy
movies there aren't sexy TV shows there
used to be magazines if you went to the
supermarket and you'd see like a sexy
person on a magazine you it was just
something that was there we've it's just
like sex is gone men are women now we're
fat is is hot like something about that
also seems like it's really screwing
with people it is young people are not
having sex at least the majority of them
are not the I mean we it used to be fun
we used to used to try to engage with
people you want you try to have sex with
people but now that goes as problems
with consent objectification
fetishization M it just it just gets a
lab or the app you just know every
freaking thing about that person first
you know all their likes and dislikes
all the food they like there's just no
mystery yeah and the other thing is
these are constructed identities too
online and it's it the and the the skill
of going up to somebody there's a whole
empty set of the skill of dating and
meeting and getting to know people and
that's that's how the self emerges is
into an interpersonal context and we
need to practice lots of that to decide
who we are in a relationship what we
like in other people how we fit with
other people takes a lot of time and
energy to figure that out what do you
make of the porn part of this
specifically related to psychological
like stuff because I was you remember
the uh what was his name Jeffrey tubin
on CNN so he gets caught whacking off on
a zoom call Y and to me what was funny
about that not was that he was doing it
as much as like in between being on CNN
that's what he's doing like like but
that a lot of people are doing that yes
that like that's like just there now
consuming and compulsive and it's it is
um it's been a grave concern of mine uh
from the addiction standpoint because
that's where we're seeing lots of that
we don't have any idea the full impact
on young people uh I will tell you what
I saw I've seen over the last 15 20
years is young
males feeling frightened they don't want
to be seen as objectifying women or
being ma toxic masculine so they pull
back they certainly wouldn't talk to
somebody who's has a beer in their hand
because that's you know they can't
consent then you know you again seen as
a predator still happens a lot where men
are told that that's the case they pull
back they head off into the porn and
they sort of hide there like okay I'm
okay I got my porn and I and they miss
the de developmental Milestones of
dating and cons you know learning to do
those things and for the first time I
had a show that just ended this year
it's kind of a sort of a love line esque
show called Dr Drew after dark over at
your mom's house Tom sigur and his wife
Christina Peep and on that show for the
first time in my career of talking to
young people young males were starting
to talk about visiting prostitutes this
was becoming part of the option to deal
with the loneliness and the disconnect
and that that's not good right that's
going to be a real mess that's probably
just the next extension of the only fans
thing then they're just like oh well you
could also pay them for this literally I
mean or person maybe who knows I mean
there somebody like who knows what yes
it's all it all goes there and then now
I'm hearing from women going where are
the men right what's going on here if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode play play
list all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell